you may well be experiencing Deja Vu by
now whether it's in the NHS the civil
service or on the railways the cycle of
ballots strikes and negotiations is
showing no sign of relenting
having only just gone on strike
ambulance workers will be asked to
consider walking out again six more
times after talks between the GMB Union
and the health secretary broke down
while discussions with doctors unions
saw little progress
haven't seen anything at the moment
that's made us change course we must
wait for the ballot we're it's a
democratic process but we do have six
weeks to change uh what happens next
the Dyers cast though when it comes to
civil servants border force staff among
a hundred thousand who will strike on
February the first talks with the
government aimed at easing tensions only
ramping them up I'm sad to say the
meeting was a complete fast what he told
us today is there is no money on the
table the government is not considering
alleviating this crisis by any means now
including one-off payments or finding
extra money all he will talk about is
2023's pay and all of the unions present
made it clear that if that remains the
government's position industrial action
is likely to escalate of all the
industrial disputes the one on the
railways may prove the hardest to
resolve it's been going on for months
but one Union the tssa told me today the
two sides are still miles apart and so
although talks are ongoing that doesn't
mean much
rmt boss Mick Lynch emerged after four
hours around the table but it wasn't
time enough for a breakthrough with
train operators we have been in detailed
discussions with the rail delivery group
for the train operating companies and we
are working
jointly towards a revised offer for
their section of the dispute
and we've agreed that over the next
couple of days we'll continue to work on
that through discussions
and we'll see what comes of it but in
better news for the government teachers
in England aren't yet ready to follow
their Scottish colleagues a strike
ballot by one Union failed to reach the
necessary turnout but elsewhere it seems
walkouts are gathering Pace Ivor Bennett
Sky News